uh some viewers sent me this clip
yesterday and I want to look at it with
you today Evangelical end times
televangelist Pastor preacher Rick Wiles
did a commentary a few days ago where he
sort of sounded almost kind of like
maybe a populist leftist certainly a
populist maybe even a populist leftist
who wants to take money from
billionaires to help the poor and some
in our audience actually got suckered
into it initially but if you actually
listen to what Rick Wiles is saying and
you understand the context of his
Evangelical Christian worldview you
realize he's merely being a conspiracy
theorist and a Nutty one at that it's
plain old-fashioned Evangelical end
times conspiracy theorism which
sometimes can sound like it's left-wing
populism but it's not now before we get
into the clip as a reminder
we've talked about Rick Wiles before
he's one of the guys who during the
Trump Administration was talking about a
Civil War and taking up arms he's the
guy that said the impeachment of Donald
Trump is an attempted Jew coup he said
if Donald Trump is removed there will be
violence I guess he was right about that
the violence was from people on his side
he said vegan burgers are a satanic plot
to destroy Souls that's the Rick Wiles
I'm talking about so let's get into this
clip and you might notice he starts
sounding sort of kind of like a
left-wing guy here take a listen if
somebody
in America
put together a political movement to do
two main things
break up the power
of the tech companies I mean bust them
up
don't just
slap their fingers bust them up
break them up
like in the monopolies of the early
1900s I mean crush the tech companies
break them up and
to
outlaw
being billionaires okay he says let's
break up tech companies let's do
antitrust enforcement that's often a
left-wing issue except when they only
care about breaking up Tech monopolies
and ignored the issue of antitrust for
decades and then he said Outlaw being a
billionaire that's something many people
on the left have talked about so so far
right wing televangelist Rick Wiles is
maybe appealing to some folks in our
audience but let's continue we've
reached the point
I I mean I'm a free enterprise person
and and I I have no
um
no ill will towards anybody in their
financial success I hey you want to be a
zillionaire a quasillionaire I don't
care all right you want to go buy a
planet go buy a planet I don't care but
when you use your money in power to
change my life to take away my rights to
try to force things on me that I object
to that I find morally repulsive when
you try to restrict my free speech
when you try to promote population
control you want to pump vaccines into
my body when you want to change society
you know what you're my enemy
you're my enemy and the only way you're
able to do it is because you're a
billionaire so then we need to take away
your billions
Bill Gates if he was working a job
seven to five if he was going to work
like everybody else Bill Gates wouldn't
be doing this stuff would he no
he's only doing this stuff because he's
a billionaire take his billions away
take it away
we need to do it in this country there
needs to be a populist movement in this
country let's break up the tech
companies let's take the billions give
the bill give the I want to take Bill
Gates's billions and give it to the poor
so already by this point
if you're a clear-thinking rational
person you should start to say this is
this is wacky right-wing stuff it might
be dressed up in left populist sounding
rhetoric but this is this is this is
wacky stuff freedom for everyone until
and then he's off the rails anti-vaxx
conspiracies decrying left-wing morality
that he claims is being imposed on him
he's already off the rails but maybe
some on the left might still be on board
but then Rick Guiles goes fully into
anti-government
anti-tax rants take a look I want to
give it to the poor
I want to strip them completely strip
them and give it to the poor I want Jack
dorsey's money I want Zuckerberg's money
I want to give it to the poor
I don't want to give it to the
government
oh my gosh
tax them and and the government get it
no give it to the poor let's take their
money and give it to the poor
let's bust up their corporations this
country would change overnight so now
it's just standard right-wing thinking
in in just a few minutes he gets into
the government sucks don't tax anyone
let's depend on charity to help the poor
exclusively an old Trope of the
libertarian right that's all this is and
yet it's another example of how
populists sounding rhetoric can fool a
lot of people until you get to the
solutions they propose and the actions
they take this is the Tucker Carlson
syndrome we can call it random person
who doesn't understand what Fox News is
doesn't understand Tucker Carlson's
background and all that they tune into
Tucker's show and they hear Tucker
ranting about corporations and deletes
doing bad things to the little guy and
we were told that we were going to have
a reinvigoration of the working class
and all this stuff
wow that that sounds almost like Bernie
and then it gets to careful black lives
matter might take your house brown
people coming in from Mexico make the
country dirtier literally a quote from
Tucker Carlson it's just another example
of that sweet sweet vocabulary of the
populist rhetoric that tricks people and
then you get to the solutions they
propose and it's standard radical
right-wick Wing stuff yeah monopolies
are bad billionaires are bad help the
poor and then whoa what just happened
here so there's Rick Wiles calling what
I call the uh pulling what I call the
old populist Switcheroo and actually
tricking some people even in my audience